wait wait wait wait First Wives Club
what is the theme of this song
um so it's like a women's empowerment
song I caught it First Wives Club
because I'm saying like You Don't Own Me
and I heard that song originally on the
First Wives Club movie and guys yeah and
I got into Goldie Hawn in that movie
Cody hi yeah what was the other I don't
remember a bunch of old white [ __ ]
was in that movie but that would be my
favorite short stuff Goldie Hawn was one
of them yes she's so bad but you ever
been married or close to getting married
yes so you've been married
you've been married in your day I've
been close to being married not actually
married though so you got you were
engaged
yeah something like that I mean did you
have a ring
we was close to giving me it was a very
very close relationship did you have a
ring
yes I'm always gonna have a ring well
they so you were engaged yeah so what
happened he cheated
it just didn't work out damn yeah we
just went into two separate
paths yeah but God bless him he's doing
really well so well that's good that's
positive usually when that kind of thing
happens you're like yo [ __ ] him he ain't
[ __ ] by the way track hates about that
[ __ ] ass [ __ ]
so get that out in my music but that's
why I don't never feel no way I get over
[ __ ] very quick
nice trait to have
yeah you gotta have a short memory I
gotta I don't got a short memory with
stuff that matters but a lot of [ __ ] is
just like
I'll be over because I'll be having so
much other [ __ ] going on in my life like
that actually matters and requires my
attention and for me to show up and be
happy and [ __ ] that I can't afford to
waste my time being mad or bitter or
anything like that like that ain't gonna
give me no money and it's only going to
make even more bad [ __ ] coming your way
you feel like now that you're you have
like a high profile as an artist
is it take a special type of Dude to
like get down with Armani Caesar because
he has to kind of understand that you're
a boss [ __ ] that you got this driving
rap career that you're a public figure
like there's so many things that like
like I think when I think of like uh
you know powerful women intimidate men
it just is what it is yeah I think
um yeah it's difficult for a man to date
a woman because I think
um at least in my case
it's already like God's Gonna judge you
off of how you look anyway and expect
you to be a certain way not realizing
like you know I actually am an Avid
Reader I like deep conversations I like
you know what I'm saying they may look
at me and Judge Me based off of you know
Instagram or whatever the case may be
like a lot of guys don't really get to
know me from me yeah so they think like
oh man I gotta have like my bag up I
gotta get her to say I gotta get her
that and it's like well or we could just
have a nice conversation that yeah can
we can we can we carry an hour
conversation where I'm not bored I want
to kill myself yeah I mean that's why
but I write songs about that all the
time like that's where the list of
little girl song came from
all of that stuff too because obviously
like if I'm gonna do it for myself I
want whoever is around me to be able to
level me like I love on me but I think
you know it's better stuff like bigger
stuff that matters I think nowadays you
know relationships are so transactional
they are like and social media only
perpetuates that they don't know so now
you don't really know how to deal with
people on just a regular human basis
without it being a transition yeah yeah
what's the uh what's the ulterior motive
what can I get out of this yeah yeah a
lot of men are paying you know to get
with the girls of their dreams and a lot
of women are getting paid for their pain